- Hello everybody.
Thank you very much for
coming all the way over
to Mandalay Bay, to
hear me talk about logs.
Now, this presentation
partly is a story about what's
really possible with AI.
And this picture here was
actually generated by Sora.
It's actually me at the 1966 World Cup,
which I am far too young
to have been a part of.
(David laughing)
Witnessing England's winning goal,
which is the only time
we've ever seen success
in a sport we invented, right?
So, (David laughing)
All right.
So let's talk a little
bit about the problem
that people are experiencing today.
Observability today has been
laid down with a foundation
of data collection,
proprietary agents,
and in a lot of ways we've
come to rely on dashboards
and visualizations,
but we're struggling to get answers.
And we have a lot of
alerts out there today,
also without context, right?
So, you know, I get an alert
about some CPU usage issue
on one of my boxes,
or my Kubernetes cluster pods
are running out of memory.
I get the alert, I just
don't have a lot of context,
I don't know what to do with it.
And this is a challenge
that we see our customers
struggle with every day.
And even when, you know,
you're looking at the outcomes,
a lot of time
is spent working on putting
together the data pipelines.
Just to get the data into
the observability solution,
you have to create lots of log pipelines,
maybe you use a log stash
or something like that,
and it takes a lot of work
and a lot of data gets
lost during this process.
So I talk to customers all the time
and they say to me things like,
"You know oh,
half of the logs
that I'm trying to get
into my solution here
are just being dropped on the floor."
And if you don't have the information,
then you spend a lot of time
wrestling with getting answers
to the problems that you have,
which increases the amount of downtime,
customers are experiencing slow systems.
I was trying to get onto
Claude earlier today actually,
and it was currently down.
So, you know, what do we do
while customers are suffering
with these problems, right?
We need to get things up and running again
and get people back online.
And part of the problem here,
is the why has been missing.
I was an SRE long time ago,
and you know, I used to work
with logs on a regular basis
to figure out what's
wrong with my systems.
And you know, back in those days,
we only had five or six different servers,
and I had a notepad file
with a list of Grep and set patterns
that we'd come up with together as a team.
I copy and paste those into my terminal
and try to find the logs that way.
And then over time,
we built systems that were
became very, very complex, right?
Microservices is everywhere,
Kubernetes everything.
We've basically built
enormously complex systems.
And as a result of that, the
industry has been telling you
to throw your logs away,
turn them into metrics,
or put all that information into traces,
but you can't rely on that, right?
Because you can't instrument
everything with traces.
You know, I think I looked
the other day at a survey
that an observability
vendor had put out there,
you can get to 50 or 60%
of traces deployed out
in your environment,
what do you do with the rest of it?
So we shouldn't be throwing
away all this log data,
we should just be being more intentional
and more intelligent about it.
So why aren't SREs using logs more?
Because there's some great
information in there.
And like I said, every time
I've solved the problem,
it usually has come down to the logs.
Well, they're messy and
unstructured, right?
So, you know, the information in there,
sometimes a little bit messy.
Sometimes you can't do
analytics on that data
because it's unstructured.
You have to pause it first,
which goes back to the pipeline
problem I was talking about.
You need to write all
these grok expressions
or regular expressions.
Actually did a search
and looked up
like what was the most
complicated regex expression.
And the first result on Google
is somebody trying to use regex
to parse a log line, right?
Which I thought was pretty funny.
And there's a lot of logs, right?
Millions, millions of logs or more.
It's volumous,
the most volumous observability
signal that we have.
And finally, there's all sorts of logs
from all over the place,
different systems.
And that problem has gotten a lot worse.
Again, when I was doing the SRE role
about 10 years ago,
things were starting to
get very complicated,
but we still had a
manageable number of systems.
We didn't have like a million
different AWS services,
for example, sending us data,
all these different SaaS
applications that we have now,
it was kind of manageable.
And every single system out
there has a different format.
And it's a shame that we
can't rely on logs more
because it's easy to collect logs.
Even SaaS applications,
typically output logs.
So you can get logs from
just about everywhere,
even, you know, mainframes, put out logs,
ATM machines, everything emits a log.
And it has a log,
logs typically have a
lot of great context.
They were written for
humans to consume typically.
And so, you know, things
like user IDs, explanations,
you know, you can read them,
they're like a novel in some ways, right?
You can actually read logs
if they're well written, of course,
and you can get a lot of
really good information
like you can see on the screen here,
the server restarted a host for example.
But what's needed to manage logs well?
Well first of all, you
need a scalable platform
because we've got a lot of logs out there,
and you need to be able to,
you need a platform that can handle
all of that at scale, right?
So, you know, if you want to write a query
or you've got a dashboard,
you want to be able to have
those things updating quickly.
You don't want to have to
wait for hours and hours
to get the results that you need
when you're trying to solve a problem.
And you need to be able to store
this stuff fairly cost effectively.
If you want to keep all your log data,
instead of throwing it away,
it needs to be in a way
that's cost effective.
And so that's what you
need on the platform side.
On the other side, we can
use AI-driven analysis
to extract incredible insights from logs,
and we'll talk a little bit
more about that later on.
But first of all,
let's talk a little bit
about what Elastic does
well already today.
We have a lot of integrations
out there in Elastic.
So we can, you know, consume logs
from a huge variety of different sources.
The platform is very, very scalable.
Customers tell me all the time
that they moved to Elastic
or they adopted Elastic
and they were very, very
impressed with the performance
of the platform.
They can get queries back in half the time
that they could before,
they can get information
on their dashboards
and they can actually see
the information quickly
without having to wait hours
for the dashboards to load.
Elastic does these things very, very well,
and we also have good
ML-driven patent analysis,
classic ML algorithms, anomaly detection,
patent analysis, things like that.
We can do really great
search and filter things.
We've had this new query
language called ES|QL.
If you haven't seen it
already, check it out.
We keep adding stuff to that all the time,
we just GA joins, which is great.
So now you can join Data
and Elastic with ES|QL
and we keep adding ML functions
to ES|QL as well, which is great.
So you can actually query a
lot of data in Elastic now,
and inside the query language,
you can send the result to an LLM
and get it to have a
look at what the issue
is from the ES|QL query directly using
the piped query language.
You just pipe it to the LLM,
have the LLM do the analysis
and it comes right back into your results.
Really fantastic.
So ES|QL has some very, very
powerful analytic capabilities.
So how do we store log data efficiently?
We recently released LogsDB index mode.
And the way it works is, is it does,
one of the main ways that it works
is that we do some additional
compression on logs.
We use index sorting,
we also use a technique
called Synthetic Source.
So now we're actually storing logs
in a columnar data format.
We can save a lot of disc space this way.
In fact, many of our
customers are seeing up to 70%
of their data storage costs
have gone down using LogsDB.
And so, you know, that's one way
we're making it so that customers
can store all their logs
without having to throw them away.
And we're going even further than that.
We haven't actually released
this particular part of Elastic yet,
but we we're currently working
on a compressed log processor as well.
So if you've got repeated log lines,
like you can see in the slide here,
we'll template those, right?
So we only store the bit of
the log line that changes.
So we can save you another 50%
in storage using this technique.
And this is completely transparent to you,
it's just happening in the background.
So we have a great platform,
you can store all your logs,
you can, you know, manually
analyze the data really nicely
with a lot of the analytic
functions that we provide.
If we take all of that power
and we bring LLMs into the picture,
we can do a lot more,
we can do some really great things
with all this log data that you have.
That means that you don't have
to go hunting and pecking,
you get the insights delivered to you.
And if we do that,
and give you those
actionable capabilities,
rather than just having to
troll through all this data,
you actually get insights
that you can action on,
then we've actually
created something magical
for you, right?
So we already talked about how we store
the data efficiently.
Once we have the data stored
efficiently in Elastic,
the first thing we do
with this new AI-powered
log analytics engine
that we're calling streams,
is we identify the systems.
So we send the logs into
Elastic, store them efficiently,
and then the first thing we
do is we look at those logs
with the assistance of an LLM
to understand what systems they come from.
And you may have tried this yourself.
I've certainly tried it myself
and it works phenomenally well,
which is take a log line,
chuck it into an LLM.
Quite often the LLM
will be able to tell you
where that log came from,
what system it came from.
It'll do some really good
analysis on the logs,
might even help you with the root cause.
So we can usually tell
just by looking at the logs
or a sample of the logs,
not just one log line,
but you know, we get a sample of the logs,
we can tell what system
it comes from, right?
So we can identify if it's Elasticsearch
or Nginx per this example.
Once we've identified
what system it comes from,
we can then start to
partition them automatically.
So we can send Hadoop blogs for example,
into a special Hadoop index.
We can send Spark logs
to a special Spark index.
Or if you have Java applications
and you've got an order
processing service,
we identify that it's an
order processing service
and we send those logs into
an order processing index.
So now we've got your logs organized
and this all happens automatically.
You can see here,
an example of how we organize that data.
So it's not just going,
one level deep like I described here.
You can go multiple levels down.
So if you've identified an
order processing system,
you might wanna separate error logs
from info logs for example, or
you may want to go higher up,
you might wanna bucket
everything under Kubernetes
and the things that are under (indistinct)
So we have a hierarchical
organization system here in play,
that enables you to organize
your logs, how you see fit,
and like I said,
using AI assistance to help you.
So once
we've got the systems,
we've identified those,
we've partitioned the data
into sensible streams,
we then want to extract
meaning from your logs.
So like at the moment most people
are still using unstructured logs, right?
I would say a good 90% of the logs
I'm still seeing out there
are completely unstructured,
and that is not good for
our analytics, right?
So the next thing you wanna do
is take that unstructured
data and structure it.
So that's the next thing that we wanna do
with our data processing pipeline.
Once we've finally done all of that,
we've actually processed your logs,
structured them, made
it easy for analytics.
The next thing we look for
is any significant events.
So like I said, you know,
we know if it's an order
processing service,
we maybe know if it's
hosted on Kubernetes,
we might know if it's a Spark system,
whatever it happens to be,
what we then do is with the
assistance again of an LLM,
we say what kinds of problems
am I likely to encounter
with this particular system?
And here are some samples
of some logs as well.
So it gets familiar with
what it's dealing with.
And it will come back and say,
you know what, this is a spark system,
there might be out of memory errors
that you're likely to encounter.
And what it does then
is it generates a query
that runs on a regular basis
to see if there are any new occurrences
of say this out of memory error.
Now you don't have to do
any of this manually, right?
This is AI doing a lot
of the work for you.
And then, we can generate assets,
we can generate dashboards,
we can generate SLOs,
we can generate things
like visualizations,
and we can even do things
like put information about the
systems that we've detected
into our knowledge base.
So if you don't know about this already,
Elastic has a Vector
database in it, right?
It's one of the big
things that Elastic does.
And all of our AI technology
in the Elastic Observability platform
is built on top of
Elasticsearch capabilities
like the Vector database.
And so we have this thing
we talk about on a regular
basis here at Elastic,
called Retrieval Augmented Generation.
So what we can do is,
is if we have the AI analyze your systems,
we can say, you know,
this is a Spark system,
these are the things you need
to think about with Spark Systems.
We can put that into the knowledge base.
And so when you are dealing
with problems within the AI assistant,
you know, having natural
conversations about your problems,
what is the root cause
of this problem and that,
it can then refer to any information
that it's recorded
about the systems that it's working with,
which will help you accelerate,
root cause analysis, right?
And this is what it looks like end to end.
There's a couple of things
that are interesting
on this slide.
Firstly, if you look at,
the bottom left hand corner on this slide,
we still support all the
existing elastic things
like integrations that we have.
If you're using Elastic Agent
or Logstash or whatever,
we still support all of
those Nginx mechanisms
with this new streams product.
You can still use those.
But naturally,
when we send data in using an integration,
we don't need to partition that data
because the integration
already tells it where to go
in Elastic and organizes
that data for you.
So,
it skips the partitioning step.
That's kind of like the legacy approach.
We'll still support that.
The new approach that we're
producing over here at Elastic
is to send your data in
using whatever you like.
It could be the Vanilla Otel Collector,
it could be Fluent Bit,
it could be, you know, whatever
it is you are using today.
It doesn't have to be Elastic Technology,
you can send it into our new logs endpoint
and we just put the logs in Elastic,
you don't have to do any
edge processing anymore,
move all of that over to Elastic,
send all the data to the log stream
and then we figure it out by
starting out with partitioning.
So that's Elastic Streams.
Now, you'll see when I show you the demo,
which I'm gonna do in a minute,
that it is like a magical experience.
So let's do that.
Let's switch over to the demo
and I'll show you what
Elastic Streams looks like.
So here we go.
This is Discover,
and I've got an ES|QL query here.
And this is a log data going
back to the previous diagram
that you just saw,
that's coming in via the classic
elastic agent route, okay?
And the first thing you'll
notice about this data
is that it's completely
unstructured, okay?
So it's just raw unstructured log data,
which is what most of you are
probably dealing with today.
At the moment, you
could probably recognize
a little bit about this data.
It looks like trading data.
And what we want to do,
is we want to structure this data.
So we're gonna click
this little button here,
pause content in Streams.
And the first thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna create a new processor.
Now, as you can see here,
we have this handy little button here
called Generate Pattern.
And it has that little AI logo
that you're probably seeing
all over the place now,
but if we click that button,
you'll see that it generates
a grok pattern for us
so you don't have to do it
manually anymore, right?
And you can see that it's
like looked at the data
and it's got some understanding
of the data, right?
So it knows that this is a stock symbol
and a quantity and a price,
and it inferred this, you know,
we didn't tell it any of that information,
we just gave it the raw
logs that you see here.
So if we accept that,
now the data is going to be much easier
to do analytics on, right?
We can now start to look at how much
did a particular stock trade
for over a 30 day window
or something like that,
which would've been much harder to do
had we left this data in
an unstructured format.
So let's save that.
One thing you'll notice here,
that's very interesting as well,
is this little source thing
here that says OpenTelemetry.
So when we do this with the
generating of the patterns,
we try to use OpenTelemetry
semantic conventions.
So we're using this open standard schema,
we store that in that
standard schema format,
natively and elastic,
so you can be sure that all your data
is being written in a standard format.
We'll confirm those changes.
And now if we go back to discover,
we can now have a look and see
how easy it is to run
analytics on that data, right?
So now we can actually do
a sum of the quantities
over the cloud regions,
and we can see that our
workloads are pretty evenly split
between all the different cloud
regions that we have there.
And we can do, you know,
other types of analytics now,
because we couldn't have done
that on the unstructured data,
not very easily,
or you would've had to
have manually created
a processing pipeline
to deal with it, right?
So,
now we look to how you do it
with the standard processing pipeline
using Elastic Agent and all
of that sort of thing, right?
Now we're gonna look at how
you do it in the new way,
which is just sending your
data to the Elastic Log index.
So this is a new special index called Logs
and we manage all the
complexity behind the scenes
like the Nginx pipelines
and things like that.
You don't have to worry
about those, we manage it.
So let's take a look at what
we wanna do with that first.
So the first thing
we would do with that
is partition the data.
So we're gonna go into partitioning here,
and of course we can
still do things manually.
We don't always have to use AI, right?
We want to give you that flexibility.
The AI isn't always gonna get it right.
And so we'll create a
partition manually first.
We'll always call it Spark.
We're gonna use a field attribute
to split off Spark logs
from the Log Stream.
So if we save that,
what's gonna happen now
is you can see this hierarchy appearing
where we've got logs at the top level,
which is where we are
just sending all our data
and now we've got a new index
that's being written to,
which is gonna contain just Spark Logs.
But we can also do this with AI.
So we click suggest partitions with AI,
and AI would've done a perfectly fine job.
In fact, we had Hadoop and
Spark Logs in the log stream
and it has split those out perfectly.
So we're gonna just save those changes.
And you can see here that we
have Spark and Hadoop logs
and you can see that hierarchy
that I talked about before.
So the log stream has
now been split into two.
We've got Hadoop logs
and Spark logs separate
from how they were.
So once they're all separated out,
we can then also do the same
processing that we did before
on those logs.
We can create a processor,
we can use AI to generate
those grok patterns,
and we can split out the
severity text using that,
and again, do a better job
of analytics on this data.
So let's confirm those changes.
And then you'll see here,
now I can run ES|QL against that data,
much, much easier.
Right.
So what have we done so far?
So we partitioned our logs,
we structured our logs, we've
ran analytics on our logs.
The next thing that we wanted to do,
if you go back to thinking
about the diagram I showed you,
is we wanna find problems
in our logs, right?
So let's take a look at the Spark logs.
And the first thing we'll
do here is we'll detect
what systems are here.
We know it's a Spark system,
but what the AI has done in the background
is it's added additional
information about the Spark system.
So you can see that description field
is kind of a cut off at the moment,
but it's got a large
description about Spark Systems
and what Spark Systems do
and what types of problems
that you might encounter
with Spark Systems.
So once we've identified the system,
and we've described the system to Elastic,
we'll add that to streams
and we'll generate suggestions
on the types of problems
that can occur with Spark Systems.
So you can see this list here,
we've got Spark Debug events,
Spark warnings, Spark
out of memory exceptions.
These are all things that are specific,
specific problems to Spark
Systems that might occur.
And by bringing them into Elastic,
we then keep track
to see if any of these
problems occur over time.
We're actually using a technique called,
change point detection,
which is a machine learning technique.
It will detect whether there is a spike
in the number of these logs over time,
or if there's a dip in
the number of these logs
or if there's a change in the
distribution in these logs.
It'll detect all of these things,
and you can get alerted to those problems,
and I'll show you how to do that.
So here what we do is,
is we actually are gonna set
up an alert based on the query
that the AI generated.
So we go in here,
and you can see
we copied the query from
here into the alert.
And now if we save that,
we will get alerted
anytime there is an out
of memory exception with our Spark system.
I didn't have to create
this query manually,
the LLM did it for me.
It actually probably
knows the Spark System
and the types of problems
that can happen with Spark
Systems far better than I do,
to be honest.
And you can see that alert
in Elastic over here.
So we've done significant events,
now we've found problems in our logs.
We've also made a lot of other
things much, much easier.
That used to be kind of
tricky to do in Elastic.
We've made things like retention
and data quality issues much easier
to see using the Streams UI.
So the next thing we're gonna
dig into is I'm gonna show you
how easy it's to do that now.
So if you look in here,
we can actually change the
retention pretty easily.
So you know, if I want to change
it to 30 days, for example,
for these particular Spark logs,
I can change it very,
very quickly in here.
I can adjust the ILM policies.
So if I want to just put,
you know, two days of hot
and 30 days of warm,
or maybe I want to use the frozen tier
to save even more money on storage,
I could do that quickly in streams.
We've just made these things
a little easier to do,
hiding a lot of the
complexity behind the scenes.
So we can set retention.
And the other thing we can
do is we can actually look
at data quality.
So if we look at the data quality here,
there's actually two types
of data quality things
that we could do.
So if you think about
data coming into Elastic,
we can tell you if there is a problem
with a particular field that's coming in,
a specific piece of data,
or we can tell you if the
entire document failed
to come into Elastic
and we store that information
in our failure store
so you can dissect it.
So I'll show you how that works.
Again, we've made it much, much easier
to do all these things in streams.
So the first thing I'm gonna do,
is I'm going to deliberately
break this regular expression.
So you can see here I've
put some nonsense in there.
We're gonna ignore failures
for this processor,
and we're gonna update that.
I'm gonna save the changes.
And now what will happen is, is,
Elastic has caught the problem.
If you see here, the
entire document has failed
because that regular expression is broken.
So it failed to bring that document
into Elastic successfully.
And we can dig into what the problem is.
So you can see here it
tells us straight away
that the provider grok expression
did not match the field value,
which stopped the data from
coming into Elastic properly.
So it's much easier now to
see when there are problems
with the data stream.
So that's one thing that's
the entire failed document,
but we also can do it on a
field level as well, right?
So if we go back here, we'll,
first of all we'll fix this
so it's not broken anymore.
And then what we'll do is we
will create a new processor,
we will use the host name
and we'll put a ridiculously
large host name for you,
that is definitely not a host name
that will fit any sort of validation logic
that I'm aware of.
(David laughing)
So we'll do that,
and then you can see what happens
in the data quality pages.
Now, instead of a failed document,
I've got a degraded document,
and that's because it's
ignoring the host name field.
And if you look at the
host name field in here,
it's because the size
of the host name is too big.
So we basically just
ignored that specific field.
We're still ingesting the document
and we're still ingesting
all the other data
or the other attributes that are in there.
We're just ignoring the host name
because that field's being corrupted.
It's got a completely ineligible
host name in it, right?
So we'll go back and
we'll fix these problems,
we'll delete this,
we'll save the changes,
and then if we go back in,
everything's working again now, right?
So that's streams.
Those are all the new goodies
that we've released in Elastic.
I'll switch back to the slides.
Here we go.
So,
you can see now why we
need a good solid platform.
We need scale to billions of logs
and do that in a way
that's cost effective.
We wanna simplify, Nginx, right?
We don't want people to have
to wrestle with pipelines
and drop data on the floor.
We want to automate as
much of that as possible.
And we now have AI that can really help us
with this automation.
And now you can spend
more time solving problems
instead of working
on log processing pipelines,
which I know is a massive
headache for a lot of you.
And we then use AI to do
a lot of analytics work
to surface problems in
your logs automatically,
to give you the ability
to, you know, find problems, for example,
that you may not even be aware of
in your Spark logs, for example.
And you know, at some point
our vision is to bring
this beyond logs, right?
Bring it to traces and metrics
at some point in the future.
So thank you very much everybody.
Thanks for joining me on
this talk about streams,
and I appreciate you coming
all the way down here
from the Venetian.
Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)